Okay, this question. I remember Ann or Michelle telling me about an alternative to pet scans here in the Twin Cities.
One that does not use radioactive sugar or something like that. I'm digging through the emails. Okay, so an alternative to pet scans, an alternative to MRI.
Is this company right here the pre-new vote pre-new vote is a new type of MRI and actually interviewed this doctor on our doctor cut our cutters clinic live.
A couple years ago, this was the last scan I did for my cancer. Now they have these units in vocal return, Dallas, Los Angeles, Minneapolis actually out in.
I wasn't that I went to say this park area. Silicon Valley, the Vancouver, British Columbia.
So they have several more that they're hoping to refurbish because they're taking MRI units and they're, you know, doing adding some technology to them to be able to give a much better picture than an MRI.
It's kind of like an MRI, the CT scan and a pet scan all had a baby. You get a pre-new vote scan.
The only negative is they're not covered under insurance, but they're trying to make them affordable for people. I think a full body pre-new vote scan is like $2,500.
I don't I think it's somewhere out there. I can't remember because mine was a year and a half ago now.
Was it yeah. And so, but this is what you want to look up pre-new vote.
And they do not use any gadolinium dies. They don't use that's the benefit. And it gives a better scan image than if they did, you know, an MRI with gadolinium.
So, it's really good empathy.